très sociable
il est passionné
bonjour mon idée mais bien nina caprez
5000 trastet coco vient mon mandat au
mois c'est bruno gauthier à bien vite de
le coin mais la quarantaine - ma passion
c'est travaille beaucoup en fait coucou
en général comme si le cocoloko en
général pas seulement très serré ce qu
ils travaillent tous déçus par cette
cause mais
tellement mon patient adam malgré mon
métier aussi j'ai passé un moment
passion mon métier même comme manger
comme dimona
comme un deuxième co sont comme on dit
quoi si l'étude des doigts comme voilà
de la racine au caire mal à faire mais
je me rappelle bien
5004 déposé pas tous nos ordis des
paiements partout partout on m'a déposé
sa grâce à mascara leurs preuves comme
on l'a connu en moins que
les gosses à droite et cela c'est comme
ça ça va recevoir ce traité
si c'est pas transmis de génération en
génération
ça va être perdu ça va ça va aller en
perdition et donc bruno en fait il
participa
à ce développement de cet artisanat
quoique ça reste en fait dans la culture
de la réunion
fait des paniers les chapeaux parole
nous faisons face à lever le mariage par
tél vous faites des décorations
en fait parce que mon iphone sa part
maintenant on regarde les
retransmettre ce bâtiment
et c'est tout à fait motivé s'ils ne
suppriment un pm fait son nid escabeau
c'est vrai mais après la vienne
on met ça c'est à dire qu'on nous
regarde et nous les à la réunion la
nôtre coco les pieds en valais et les
endormis par
6 à la solitaire en semaine c'est un
niveau d'activité très sage kokkola mois
les fiasson continents montre un
bâtiment assez valorisés pc marmaille
nue qui a pris la relève